I am a Camille friends aka hair guru I'm
a third generation hair stylist I really
believe that I was born a hair stylist
there's nothing else I ever wanted to do
I was really fortunate to land on two
good movies one of my first beginning
movies was 8 mile and then I did a whole
bunch of Eddie Murphy movies then we get
into dream girls and then we go to
superheroes and and Here I am I waited
my entire life for this I'm a burn at
all it was really a lot of thought about
how we were gonna do it how we were
gonna break it down and really start
looking at African culture and then
looking at modern culture and even
Futuristics cultures to come up with
what where Conda was gonna look like
whatever I can dream of I can create and
they were open to allowing me to give
all the characters different looks so we
got the opportunity to go as far as we
want you know we did braids we did locks
we did wigs we did hair extensions just
a gamut of different things IMAX is the
best way to see it because I'd love to
see where you see the texture and skin I
look when you see like the texture in
the fabric like all those little minor
details what happens now determines four
techniques to the rest of the world mr.
Sanford
why do we do movies because we love
making and that's why I'm here because I
love making movies and IMAX is the best
high quality experience in singular
[Music]